uh wants to bc i mean although that alex
charles has been taking questions boris
johnson wants to own
uh the cop he certainly wants to stop
nico sturgeon uh owning the climate
change summit so um he'll put his stump
on it but the other big thing
of course is the budget next week so
that'll come up too here he goes and
others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings
later today let's head to the north west
with direct quick derek
thank you mr speaker halton council ran
out of funding for discretionary covered
isolation payments despite a strict
criteria for elizabeth
just 171 constituents have been helped
the council have applied for further
funding but what the governments have
offered will not be enough
other constituents fail to qualify for
help due to the criseria set by his
government will the prime minister look
again at this and bring forward a
properly funded scheme so that no
constituent is in a position where they
cannot afford to isolate
we need this to happen it would be like
we are to continue to drive down
covid19 infections prime minister
i thank him and i paid tribute to the
work of everybody on halton council for
everything that they've been doing
throughout this
uh pandemic i know it's been very tough
on uh council officials indeed on
everybody
else so we've uh contri we've central
governments put in another 4.3 billion
pounds to help councils uh throughout
the pandemic
uh we will continue uh to support our
local authorities and
he'll be hearing more from the
chancellor next week
let's head across to duncan baker duncan
thank you mr speaker if the uk has
become the saudi arabia of wind power
then it is off my coast of north norfolk
that is surely the capital
but the current piecemeal and
environmentally damaging connection
method
to the national good is holding us back
and this was proven by the vatinfold
judicial review
just last week we need legal and
regulatory reform
now prime minister could this be a job
for the new task force the innovation
and regulatory reform
to help us implement the much needed
offshore transmission network
and meet our net zero targets prime
minister
yes indeed and i congratulate my
honorable friend on his campaign to make
his consistency the
the riyadh or possibly the jeddah of uh
of offshore wind uh but i can tell him
that we are certainly
looking at the issue of uh the
transmission
network review and we're in the process
of develop
of developing the necessary regulatory
changes
we now come to the leader of the
opposition
thank you mr speaker the principles
behind the prime minister's recovery
plan
of caution and it must be irreversible
are plainly right
but one of the biggest threats to that
is misinformation about the risks of the
deadly virus
for example there have been people
saying that cobit statistics
appear to have been manipulated that
monday's roadmap is
based on dodgy assumptions and false
modeling
does the prime minister agree that these
kinds of comments are
irresponsible and undermine our national
recovery
prime minister uh mr speaker the
uh road map that we've set out well i
believe
uh set us on a cautious but uh
irreversible journey to freedom and
i'm glad that he supports the four steps
of uh
march the eights for schools eight for
12 for shops may the 17th hospitality
uh june the 21st for everything in the
data supporting all of that
uh mr speaker has been available uh to
the house
uh since i announced it on monday
i think the prime minister dodged that
question uh no doubt because
all those comments came from his own mps
some of the 60 or so members of the
kovid recovery group
perhaps the prime minister should have a
word with them
another big threat another big threat to
the recovery plan
is that around three in 10 people who
should be self-isolating
aren't doing so that's a huge gap in our
defenses
and the small changes on monday won't
fix it
that's why labour has called for the 500
pound self-isolation payment
to be made available to everybody who
needs it
will the prime minister just fix this mr
uh mr speaker he knows very well that uh
the
uh those who are asked to self i say
already have the 500 pound
uh test and trace a support payment and
i think he also knows because he
he supported the uh the road map on on
monday that the
uh elijah he supports that the
eligibility criteria are being extended
to allow parents and guardians to
uh who are staying off work uh also uh
to receive a payment
provided they meet the criteria i think
he's aware of that
mr speaker three out of ten people who
should be self-isolating aren't doing so
that matters to millions of people and
it matters if we're going to get the
virus under control
the chair of test and trace said that
people are scared
to come forward for a covid test because
they can't afford to isolate that's the
chair of test and take can't afford it
the government's biosecurity centre
concluded that unmet financial need was
why
some lower income areas are seeing
stubbornly high
infection rates so why after
all the billions the government has
thrown around is it still people in
low-paid jobs who are at the bottom
of this government's priorities
[Music]
actually mr speaker i think most people
uh looking at
uh what we've done throughout this
pandemic looking at the
support the 280 billion package of
support
uh can see that it is uh the poorest and
the neediest in society those
on the lowest income who have been the
top of the government's priorities
and that is quite right that's and we
will continue uh
to act in that way mr speaker and uh he
will be hearing more about that
next week from the chancellor in
addition uh to the discretionary funding
we've given councils
uh to support those who need it most
including those mr speaker who have to
self-isolate
mr speaker here's the difference if you
need 500 pounds to isolate
you're out of luck if you've got the
health secretary's whatsapp
you get a million-pound contract
turning to next week's budget now i
don't expect the prime minister
to preempt what's in the budget if i
want that
i can read it on the front page of the
times but couldn't the prime minister
at least agree with me today that now is
not the time for tax rises
for families and for businesses prime
minister
mr speaker i don't know about about you
uh but the
the budget is happening uh next week
it's
not a date that is concealed from the uh
right honourable general model he knows
when it's he knows what's happening he
knows what it what to expect but it's
preposterous for him uh mr speaker to
talk about tax prices when he started on
a manifesto
uh only a year ago mr speaker a little
over a year ago
to put up taxes by the biggest amount in
the history
of this country it is the labor party mr
speaker
his labor council in camden uh that puts
up taxes
across the country that is the way
labour behave and it's thanks to prudent
fiscal management
by this government that we've been able
to fight this pandemic
in the way that we have he wants to talk
about tax rises
and he should because this matters
councils up and down the country being
forced to decide now
whether to put council tax up that's a
two billion pound rise on families
i'm not blaming councils they've been
starved of funding for a decade
and labor and conservative councils are
in the same position
for example the premise might want to
concentrate on his own constituency
his own council hillingdon conservative
ron hillington
is voting to increase tax council tax by
4.8
just the prime minister think that
they're right to do that
mr speaker hillington council in common
with
uh most conservative councils has been
running lower taxes
a lower council taxes than neighbor up
and down up and down
he's completely wrong mr speaker i'm
going to correct him uh he the top
10 highest council taxing councils in
this country are run by
the labour party mr speaker and they're
they're they are all going to
they're all going to put their taxes up
mr speaker
except for one in those top ten which is
burnley
which is currently in over no overall
control
uh mr speaker and uh he talks about
uh uh he talks about london and my own
record on
on taxes he should talk to uh the labour
current labour
mayor of london who is putting up his
council tax
by ten percent uh because i can tell him
that the previous the previous
conservative
mayor of london mr speaker cut council
tax by 20
that's what conservative councils do
here
the fact is mr speaker that 15 billion
pounds has been taken out of council
budgets over the last
10 years the prime minister shot blaming
others for the damage he's done and he
quotes the mayor
he quotes the mayor this was the former
mayor who brought water cannon that can
be used spent millions on a garden
bridge that never got booked remember
more recently they're going to pay rose
to dominic cummings
mr speaker this is another pmq's
with yet again no answers and the truth
is this
the government spent a decade weakening
the foundations of our economy and our
country
as a result we have the highest death
toll in europe
we have the worst recession of any major
economy families are facing council tax
rises
and millions can't afford to
self-isolate and all the prime minister
offices
are returned to business as usual next
week's budget is a chance to choose a
different path
to build a stronger future to protect
families
to give our key workers the pay rise
they deserve
and to back british businesses by
supporting a hundred thousand new
startups
will the prime minister do so prime
minister
oh mr speaker if you'll only wait till
next week i think you'll find that we'll
do
far more uh than that poultry uh that
poultry
agenda that he set out uh far more than
that
and i must say mr speaker it is quite
mystifying to see the way the right
honourable gentleman
uh weaves hither and john uh like some
sort of druidical rocking stone
uh mr speaker one week he uh one week he
claims
that he supports the vaccination uh
rollout
uh the next week he actually attacks the
vaccine task force when they're spending
money to try to reach
hard to reach vaccine resistant groups
and says that kind of spending
uh can't be justified uh what one would
he calls for us to go
go faster with vaccines when he would
have stayed
in the european medicines agency which
would have made that rollout
impossible uh mr speaker he vacillates
mr speaker we vaccinate and we're gonna
get on
and we're gonna get on with our agenda
cautious
but irreversibly taking this country
forward on a one-way
road to freedom and i very much hope
that his support
which has been so evanescent in the past
will genuinely prove
irreversible this time mr speaker let's
head to yorkshire with andrea jenkins
andrea thank you mr speaker
the prime minister's roadmap will
provide many of my constituents in molly
and outward with a vision of hope for
the future
that life will be set to return to a new
normal before the end of june
and allow us to celebrate the great
british summer can the prime minister
inform the house of the preemptive
actions that the government is taking
to spot to prevent and limit the damage
of any future health emergencies
that look so that local economies and
constituencies like mine
have a sense of certainty that this will
be their last lockdown
prime minister yes she's quite right to
raise
uh the issue of local outbreaks and how
to tackle them
uh that's and particularly with the
threat of new variants which he rightly
raises and that's why we have a very
tough border regime
but also a program as we go forward for
surge testing uh door-to-door uh testing
to ensure that when
there is a a local outbreak we keep it
keep it local and keep it under control
as we're as we're trying to do at the
moment as she knows with the south
african variant
let's head to roscoe and lockheed with
the leader of the smp in blackfoot
here thank you mr speaker next week's
budget gives the opportunity to tackle
the financial costs of this pandemic the
uk has suffered its worst recession
in 300 years we now need a government
that understands the scale of this
crisis
yet at the very moment that the recovery
needs maximum investment to recover
the tories are threatening austerity
cuts that will leave lasting scars in
all our communities
families have already seen their income
slashed under this government and now
the
tories want to impose a public sector
pay freeze
and cuts to universal credit so will the
prime minister rule out a return to tory
austerity cuts
and commit to a major fiscal stimulus
of at least five percent of gdp or will
he threaten the recovery
and move millions of people worse off
prime minister i'm proud mr speaker of
the massive investments that the uk
treasury has made
throughout the whole of the united
kingdom uh 13 billion pounds and more
going to scotland
uh huge sums going throughout the the
country and i i must say i wish that the
scottish nationalist government
uh would would spend that money better
because it's very sad to see some of the
failures in education policy
in in scotland the failures in their uh
criminal justice policy and fighting
crime
and i think what the people of the whole
uk would like to see and i believe the
people of scotland is less talk
about a referendum mr speaker which is
his agenda
and more talk about the real issues
facing our country
go back to me in blackfoot in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker the prime
minister's boasting but the cold
hard reality is that the united kingdom
has suffered the worst
slump of any major economy and 120 000
people have lost their lives that's
under
your guidance prime minister coronavirus
has exposed the deep inequalities
under this broken westminster system
after a decade of tory cuts
millions of families are in poverty and
uk
unemployment is soaring in contrast
in the united states president biden
understands what is needed
he has proposed a 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus package to restart and renew
the american economy
prime minister will your government
follow the example of the us
and boost the economy like biden or does
the tory plan
to return to type and impose yet another
decade
of touring austerity prime minister
uh mr speaker the the this government is
investing a 640 billion pounds in
infrastructure
alone uh throughout the the uk uh a
massive program to get our country
rebuilt and and restarted again and i
think that is what people
uh would like to focus on rather than uh
his agenda
uh to talk about it talking about our
broken politics our broken
uh our broken uh country all they want
to do is break up britain with another
referendum and i think that is the last
thing this country needs at the moment
thank you mr speaker my right humble
friend the prime minister
knows how important that the rail link
between southport and manchester
piccadilly is for my constituents and
those living in the wider lancashire
area
all of the changes put forward by the
manchester rail recovery task force are
unacceptable they would stop this this
service from happening
and uh take our levelling up agenda off
track
will my rightful friend meet with me to
discuss changes to these proposals
so that we can keep this service and
keep my constituents uh with the service
that they've come to rely on and
which is vital for their economy prime
minister
i congratulate my honorable friend for
uh his campaign
uh for better local transport and we are
investing massively in uh
in rail connectivity in uh in his area
in in local bus routes and the
particular line
that he advocates i know is one of great
interest to uh my right on with
the secretary of state for transport and
uh i will make sure that uh he has a
chance to discuss it personally with him
let's go across to ed david and davey
can i start by thanking the government
for their change of policy announced
today
on the vaccination priority for people
with learning disabilities
despite the prime minister's rather more
equivocal answer to me on this
last monday mr speaker
today millions of uyghur people in china
live in fear under a cruel regime
the bbc international media and human
rights ngos are all reporting
on forced labour camps women being raped
and sterilized
and families being separated this is a
genocide
happening in front of our eyes so does
the prime minister agree with me
that unless china ends this genocide
britain and team gb should boycott the
winter olympics
in beijing next year prime minister
mr speaker the uh
right honourable gentleman is absolutely
right to highlight the uh
appalling campaign against the uyghurs
in
uh in xinjiang and that's why uh the
foreign secretary might run with the
foreign secretary has uh set out the
policies that he
has the package of measures to ensure
that
no british companies are complicit in or
profiting from
violations uh we're leading
international action
in the u.n to hold china to account and
will continue to work with
the u.s friends and partners around the
world to do just that he raises a point
about
a sporting uh boycott we're not normally
in favor of sporting boycotts
in this country mr speaker and uh that's
been the long-standing position
of this government i said to north
cumbria with dr neil hudson
dr hudson thank you mr speaker
penrith and the border struggles with
poor broadband and phone signal
connectivity
with download speeds around 56 of the uk
average
many of my constituents have been quoted
large and unfeasible sums for new cables
to be installed
which is often their only option to
improve coverage i welcome the potential
of the shared rural network the gigabit
voucher scheme and the universal service
obligation to help
but what reassurance can my right
honourable friend give my constituents
that government is striving to address
these broadband and phone signal not
spots
in rural cumbria prime minister
i thank my honorable friend and and all
for all he does to campaign for
the the hardest to reach areas in rural
cambrian i know that we're doing all we
can because i raise it virtually every
day
uh and we are rolling it out as as fast
as we can we've committed
uh about five billion pounds to connect
those areas
a billion pound uh for the shared rural
network
agreement and a voucher scheme to target
predominantly
uh rural areas but we are intending to
get everything we can
possibly done uh by uh in the next five
years
let's head north to dame diana johnson
damn diana
thank you mr speaker is the 40
cut to transport for the north's budget
part of the prime minister's plans for
leveling up the north
prime minister uh there's been no such
cut mr speaker and we intend to invest
massively
in in northern power as well in railways
in the north
and across the entire country
let's head to susana webb susan
thank you mr speaker whilst hospitality
has had to close their doors
in true black country spirit many of my
venues are being truly entrepreneurial
and now offer a great takeaway service
to celebrate this entrepreneurial spirit
i am launching a favorite takeaway
competition in my constituency today
will the prime minister join me in
launching this competition and also in a
takeaway from the winning entry when
he's next in wonderful starbridge
he'll receive a very warm welcome and
i'm happy to throw in a trip on the
country's finest shuttle
which i hope soon to see called the
starbridge dasher
prime minister yes i i congratulate my
honorable friend what she's doing to
champion takeaways in starbridge i'm not
sure it'd be environmentally friendly
for me to order a
takeaway from starbridge uh for in in
westminster but
uh we'll i thank her very much for her
initiative and i
uh look forward to uh visiting uh
the the the hospitality sector in her
constituency
as soon as possible we're streeting yeah
thank you mr speaker the education and
well-being recovery of children from the
pandemic is one of the biggest
challenges
facing our country but we went into this
pandemic with rising child poverty
a widening attainment gap and school
funding falling
in real terms so given that does the
prime minister really believe
that the 43 pence per pupil per day
announced today really cuts it and if he
does
would he really be happy to see that
amount spent on his own children
prime minister mr speaker i passionately
disagree with what he's just said about
uh the spending that was going on even
before the pandemic
uh we'd inquiry we're increasing funding
for primary schools
up to four thousand pounds per pupil at
five thousand
uh for secondary school pupils putting
up uh starting salaries for teachers
uh across the board uh to thirty
thousand a massive investment
in education across the board and in
further education
as well and the catch-up funds now
amount to two
billion pounds but no he's wrong they
amount to two billion pounds
mr speaker and yes we will have to do
more because this is the biggest
challenge our country faces and we will
get it done we're able to do it because
we've been running a strong economy and
we had the resources to do it because we
hadn't followed the bankrupt policies of
himself
and the party opposition
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker janine mcguire in
my constituency who is a mother of three
suffered a very unusual and unexpected
and immediate cardiac arrest which saw
her
sadly pass away in february 2000 20
years later
in august of last year one of her
daughters cara suffered
strangely the same fate with an
unexpected cardiac arrest
fortunately her friend michael's with
her who was a former soldier and thus
trained in
first aid and life-saving despite her
heart stopping for 20 minutes he managed
to save her life
in september of last year the uk
government made it mandatory for cpr
uh skills to be taught in secondary
schools but despite a campaign and a
letter from
all of my welsh conservative colleagues
the education minister in wales has
declined to do so
with my right old friend throw the
weight of his office behind my campaign
to have cpr skills taught in wales
so that the maguire family and those
like them no longer have to suffer
in such tragic circumstances well i
think the sympathies of the whole house
uh will be with uh my honorable friends
uh constituent uh family and and friends
and i agree with him very much about the
importance of learning cpr that's why we
introduced it into the curriculum
uh for all state-funded schools in uh in
england
uh it is it is of course a devolved
issue and i
share uh his uh his urgency that it also
should be adopted in wales as well let's
head to lancashire with rosie cooper
rosie
thank you mr speaker um much focus
of late has been on children returning
safely to school
in my constituency successive cohorts of
pupils
have had to wade through overflowing
grains to get into school
and are routinely evacuated from flooded
classrooms
that takes a huge toll on the quality of
their learning
will the prime minister work again with
lancashire county council
and the head teacher of town green
primary school to ensure that no child
in west lancashire
loses a vital day of education
especially
to flooding related issues prime
minister
i i thank her very much i i i sympathize
very much with her constituents and
the pupils who have to uh put up with
disruption caused by
flooding i know that the environment
agency continues to work very actively
with the county with the county council
uh to uh resolve the issues and that uh
the deaf pro minister has has written to
her about what more can be done
let's head to charles watling giles
thank you mr speaker now my right old
honourable friend will know the
pubs have been closing all over britain
for decades now tearing the hearts out
of communities
now this terrible pandemic has made
things even worse but part of the
problem is undercutting by cheap
supermarket booze
but but now we're out of the eu surely
we can do as we please with beer duty
differentiation in favor of on sales
could deliver great benefits
to pubs in communities like clankton at
nil cost of the taxpayer
will my right honourable friend commit
ministers to look at this
differentiation proposal
uh prime minister uh mr speaker he makes
an extremely good point which i'm sure
will be
uh heard with great interest around the
the country and
uh there is a just such a review uh
being carried
out after consulting uh pub owners and
brewers and and others and i know that
the chancellor
is looking very closely at the findings
let's say no to alex cunningham
alex mr speaker i was disappointed that
the prime minister didn't accept my
offer to meet with him when he recently
visited my constituency's
wonderful fujifilm vaccine complex in
billingham
to celebrate our local success story i
could have taken him to nearby billiam
food bank where he would have learned
that over
a third of the children in my
constituency live in poverty
and yet two and five of those same
children are still not entitled to
preschool meals
because the threshold is so low will the
prime minister urgently address this
scandal
take long-term action on universal
credit and school meals
and help free our children from poverty
prime minister mr speaker i
i i certainly uh i'm proud of what
universal credit is he
on to be attacked uh by a labor member
over universal credit when it's
his party's policy to abolish uh that
that that benefit
uh but uh the most the best thing we can
do
for families in in in billiam is ensure
that there are very good jobs and it was
wonderful to see what's happening in
in t side under the leadership of mayor
ben houchen
the investment that is going in by
fujifilm and others which will create
long-term jobs and it's the belief of
this side of the house mr speaker
that that is the route out of poverty uh
it's fantastic education
and top quality jobs and that's what
this government aims to deliver
said to the southwest with jack the
president jack
thank you mr speaker my right honourable
friend will recall from his visit in
2019 that the port of bristol
will make an excellent location for a
great western freeport
and the west of england mayor tim boles
has submitted a bid which could create
50 000 jobs in the region
well the prime minister back heartbeat
and also agree with me that with house
prices in the west of england sitting at
nine times average earnings we need a
home building revolution
to provide much more affordable housing
for our young people
as we build back better prime minister
my honorable friend is absolutely right
in what he says about
about home building and about the need
for housing across the the country
because you sometimes hear though this
is a problem just uh mainly in london
and the south it's not at all it's
everywhere in the country as he
as he rightly says uh and i want to
thank every i want to thank by the way
um tim bowles uh for what he's done uh
the the mayor for the western
everything that he has uh that he has
done now as he
stands down and uh we intend to uh help
build on his legacy with a massive uh
home building program
and home ownership program home
ownership programs speaker
across the country let's head to
cumbernauld with stuart c mcdonald
stewart c
thank you mr speaker before the budget
is finalized could the prime minister
ensure that his chancellor reads the
trustworth's new report
dignity or destitution the case for
keeping the universal credit lifeline
his government has been incredibly
generous to pals with ppe contracts
so surely instead of cutting employment
related benefits to the lowest real
terms level in 30 years
he must now afford some basic dignity to
six million people on universal credit
and make the uplift permanent prime
minister
mr speaker we will continue to look
after people throughout this pandemic
and beyond and the best thing we can do
across the whole of the country is to
bounce our economy back as fast as we
can
get people into high quality jobs as i
said
uh to the previous member that is the
agenda of this government
final question christian thank you mr
uh speaker um i'd like to start by
thanking my writer for wolf and the
education secretary
uh for his announcement of a new high
school for radcliffe
on the back of my campaign this new high
school will be the kickstart for
regeneration that the town
is desperately in need of the towns like
radcliff and prestwich
which haven't received uh town's fund or
future high street funding
can my right-of-wall friend advise what
assistance this leveling of government
can provide to make sure these towns
aren't forgotten well first of all mr
speaker i congratulate
my honorable friend for his successful
campaign uh to
uh get a new high school is absolutely
vital the best place for
uh for kids is in uh as in school as we
we'll hear from the
labour party very shortly uh and uh we
are
we are investing in uh his area mr
speaker
uh to the tune of 660 million pounds and
more through the local growth fund
uh 54 million pounds through the getting
uh
building fund uh and of course also in
the
transport network and next week the
whole house will be hearing even more
about what we propose to do to steer a
path
uh cautiously but irreversibly mr
speaker out of this pandemic and allow
this economy
to recover and to build that better
across the whole of the united states